I'm this close to quitting my podcast
why
I want to do I feel like I'm God I mean
look at what an [__] seriously who
wants to who likes that guy
like why would you like that guy why
would you what why would you watch on
Netflix a special called special weshi
would you like does this kid have autism
what the [__] see this is what I love
about you man you know you're tall
you're handsome you're built and your
patreon tears are muffin butts bubble
butts and closeted Chrissy yes and then
support the Puerto Rican chaos it's the
last one and it's not doing well my
patrons falling off cliff and my podcast
has stalled so I think there's I think
that's why sometimes I'm motivated to be
like you know what I'm just gonna I can
control stand up yeah I still got people
coming to see my stand-up ticket sales
all that and something that I love
because I'm wondering am I just doing
the podcast was am I just doing the
podcast now because it sells tickets and
because it's a platform that everybody
else is doing because stand up I started
because I was like I've always wanted to
be a stand-up yeah so it's organic but
this stuff I'm like am I doing that this
is like all to support the stand up but
I'm like at at some point you have to
have confidence to be like I think I've
done enough stand up where my fans are
going to be there with me whether I'm
doing the pot or not they're going to
come see my stand-up I hope mommy says
yeah I mean my only argument to that is
the algorithm is such a [__]
that I think
I think we do live and die by it a
little bit at this point right so I
think I think no I think you got to keep
doing it the podcast I think you do yeah
but doesn't that but doesn't it feel
then like it's almost like a Black
Mirror episode like this
I want to say a gilded cage because my
cage isn't that gilded but it does feel
like you're like you're gonna they're
forcing you to do things you don't want
to do
right in a way yeah but I would say I
think that's the big shift in
entertainment is I think
uh the previous generation of
entertainment you got to focus on one
thing or you got to have focused efforts
at points in your career you know kind
of like we were talking about before
like all the stages you go through like
if you landed on a sitcom or if you do
radio it's like that's your thing but
because there's a bazillion platforms
there's a bazillion types of media you
kind of have to be firing on all
cylinders in all places right to just
remind let it float yeah and now we're
in a weird thing where uh I think we're
all regardless of if you're a comedian
or you make [__] makeup tutorials or
whatever I think you're like we're all
perpetually in this place we're all
having to fight for the space yeah to
remind people like oh yeah this dude
exists or oh yeah this person exists but
do you feel like you want your whole
life to be content no not me personally
so I'm pretty like I yeah I I think what
you're describing is like just a Comics
mindset right I think comedians
especially they just have that strong
like I just want to entertain right you
know I just want to offer something
that's funny right and uh if it feels
half-baked I think that's when you start
getting this like why the [__] do I do
this right yeah I think because there's
a part of me now I guess like being a
dad kids you know traveling so much I'm
like
dude you know if I stopped putting all
my life out on YouTube all the time I
would still have my stand up I still do
my stand up every night put those
products out it's like yeah maybe it's a
little bit less tickets but it's still
like you can still like live your life
like how much how much [__] do you need
like you know what I mean like do you
need to be the best that ever did it and
worth a hundred million dollars it's
like if that's what you want then yeah
you gotta [__] keep up this pace
that's fair but if you don't if you're
like dude I just want to do stand up and
be it I don't want to miss my kids
soccer practice then I'm like you know
that's another clip I saw of you oh yeah
and I started crying well I was on
Fentanyl
fennel makes you sad yeah it does for me
when I make can I mix it with my you
know ozempic yeah
um that's why you're so skinny I was
epic as [__] knocking [__]
out yeah did you take it no hell no dude
I have got nothing to give yeah but I
don't know all you kids micro though
[__] I don't know if you keep saying
those kids like on 10 dude
I only I dude I was a freshman and you
were a senior
oh that's right we would have been in
the same more or less yeah I'm five
years older than you yeah I can still be
your dad
you think some cultures dude yeah yeah
depends how early you're hitting that
puberty here's the thing here's the
problem with stand-ups right so it used
to be
stand-ups you know only our only
platform was you know the 15 minutes or
hour long set we were gonna get that
night where now some of the
best comedy that we're doing is on the
podcast and then when you come see me do
stand-up I would have told a story or
done a bit on a podcast that just came
naturally in conversation or whatever
and then I try to reframe that as a
stand-up bit and the people like I heard
that you [__] did that I heard that
bad I'm just tired of like forcing
myself to talk about something I don't
really [__] care about look at this
[__] nobody cares look man we can
talk offline about this but I I think I
know what it is
the the thumbnails
we can start there yeah what the [__]
are we looking at man yeah what is the
focus here yeah I know
I know this looks like a 39 year old's
thumbnail if I'm being honest yeah
yeah that's what I'm saying I'm like
working for you like do you have staff
um yeah I got two people that are also
39. okay let's start there why don't we
get a young person in the mix that's
like now
you can get a a newer fan base that's
like oh man this guy's trying right
right okay that's good there's a good
point you know look at that see that I
need more [__] like this yeah yeah just
make my put a filter on and put a dick
in my face yeah yeah
I mean you wanted to start only fans
dude we can get you fired up right now
because yeah I look at this and I'm
interested I'm like is this a guy is
this a girl is that you want me I want
you dude I'm just like this is I look at
this person I say this person's for
everybody yeah this is good yeah these
are good the views aren't
don't worry about the views yeah you
think the views don't matter as much
anymore I don't think so I think the
only way you're getting like millions of
views per episode is you're having to
put like the craziest [__] right it's
just and it's that's that goes back to
that diminishing returns thing it just
gets old for me it's about ticket sales
that's the barometer that matters to me
in my life if I'm selling out selling
tickets I'm in a good place if I'm not
selling tickets I'm like why do the
people of Kansas City hate me you know
oh New York New York is my own New York
is really the only thing you know New
York's a thing I like truly care about
you know because it's home in New York
we're doing good with tickets but Kansas
City not so much Kansas oh my God Kansas
City Omaha Nebraska even Las Vegas I got
Las Vegas at the end of the month
September 30th at the cosmo nobody gives
a [__] people like oh it's a last minute
people buy the last minute I'm like it's
a 2500 Cedar we have like 10 tickets
sold so what do you think just 2008 this
is a brutal Market though yeah I know
it's tough I know see that's that's the
thing we all give ourselves reasons for
why if things aren't going well why it's
okay and I get it but it's like you know
there's other people that'll sell out
five shows there and it's like they're
just good well you got to be happy with
what you have right dude popularity also
is you can't really control it now the
people choose you control your output
not your outcome yeah yeah the people
choose yeah but I think you know we can
uh I mean
let's look at this [__] yeah the
Tesla versus Edison who cares
I think people there are people that
care yeah but there's probably things
you could lean into that you're not
really aware of because you're 39. you
know what some of these some of these
things too you know what some of these
things I'm doing too I I don't care like
Tesla versus Edison that was like my
producers like you should do an episode
on this I'm like I really don't care
she's like ah it'll be good content and
your producer's 39 yeah yeah we need to
get a 25 year old producer in there yeah
I need a 25 year old genderless kid back
there
that literally I don't know that might
make you interesting dude I don't even
know what's going on but I just need you
to tell me what to do that's what we
need yeah okay how do your how does your
New York comedy community feel about
especially weshy and Tiki wiki and I
think probably they don't I think
probably you know you they don't love it
um and but but do you love it but I love
it see that's the thing yeah I think
ultimately the only sin you can create
in comedy because it's all subjective
whether I think it's funny is [__]
irrelevant okay it's like if the
person's fan sick they're funny then
guess what they're funny everything the
only sin you can commit is stealing
someone's material as long as you're not
stealing anybody's material
fine yeah you want to make a a hack
premise joke about airline food do it as
long as it's your own original idea yeah
you know that's all so for me I'm like
you know I don't know if he's just fine
tikiwick is just fine never heard
anybody else say it especially where she
I I couldn't think of a name for
anything special so I literally asked my
two-year-old but she thought she said
especially well she I said call Netflix
and they were like are you serious I
said dude I don't give a [__] pull the
trigger